hey guys this is dennis the founder i
think here and i'm david griffin
resident comic book and video game guru
and this is our review of the walking
dead season four episode 14.
the grove yes the big one the big one
like the one everyone's gonna like the
deal break either you're on the show now
or you hate it this is the deal breaker
this is the big one so i have to say
i really liked it
i think
it's probably one of the best episodes
of walking dead since season two
hmm
uh i
okay so before i go into because i don't
want to burst he's off the train i'm off
the train but that's just because of my
feelings about the show
first of all let me say let me give it
up to mcbride i thought she did an
awesome job in this episode acting as
carol she did a great job she put on a
great performance
it's just the mood of the show i think
for me i just it's having i'm having a
lot of trouble getting to you you guys
have heard me talk now for what is this
episode 14 for 14 episodes this season
just kind of struggling getting into
this and i think this maybe the show
isn't for me anymore but
uh
there were moments that were good uh
this carried a story from the comic
books changed it changed the characters
changed the arc which is fine
uh it's just
i don't know i couldn't get into i
didn't get emotionally tied to this girl
who got shot
because honestly i kind of wanted to die
anyway but look i look i got family i
have little baby cousins i like little i
like kids i love kids i don't want to
see little kids get killed but this girl
is annoyed i'm like ah she's off the
show what pissed me off was that little
the cute one the little one i loved her
i thought she was so cool this episode
like she was being honest she like she
knew she wasn't as strong as her
switcher but she like you know she put
to pick up the gun had that moment to
herself where she killed a zombie i
really liked her character and i was
pissed that she she was killed i'm like
if you're gonna keep your girl around
keep the little one around and get rid
of the other one but you know this is
just the way it goes you know yeah
because she was she was the weaker of
right too right and i'm and i'm avoiding
this i'm avoiding talking about the
comics because if i didn't talk about
the arc from where this came from it
would spoil a lot of it and i won't
because that arc of the story is called
fear the hunters it's volume
11 i think in the walking dead if you're
reading the trades and so i don't want
to spoil the rest of which is still to
come but um they did change some things
that didn't bother me it just i didn't
get i wasn't emotionally touched
by the scene with carol and her shooting
the the girl just didn't do anything for
me see i really liked it because they
actually
had planted a lot of these things
throughout this whole season
you know you had the whole actually even
to last season with the the the rats the
killing of the rats the feeding the
zombies with the rats uh they even tied
up uh tyrese's not storyline but
uh the death of karen yeah
with carol there's that moment i thought
it was really really good that was
attention-filled where they go out into
the field this is before any of the
craziness happens right right and he's
holding the gun but he's holding the gun
for protection but you don't know if he
knows that carol had killed karen or not
no no and there's a moment where carol
looks like she's about to confess and
there's moments where tyrese looks like
he already knows and then he might off
off carol right there yeah yeah so i
really liked that moment and they had
built up that nicely throughout the the
whole season
and then with the whole lizzy thing you
know we kind of knew there was something
wrong with her
especially you know in in the beginning
of this season with the
with the father when the father was
dying and they they wanted her to to
kill him yeah yeah and they made her
look at the flowers like just like at
the end of this episode so i think they
they planted a lot of these things
and i can't say the same about other
story lines that that walking dead has
been in
you know i can't you know i still stand
by all the other episode reviews that
we've done and other episodes that i did
that i didn't like right i happen to
really like this one because i i do
think they actually
led up to this
in in a good way yeah i mean i always
defend you and
try to defend us in general i think with
the walking dead you know you don't have
to like every aspect of the walking dead
to enjoy the walking dead i might be
turned off by this episode i'm getting
turned off by the show more and more
might be my last season with the show
but i still love the i love the comic
books i like the walking dead telltale
video game that we review on think
heroes so i mean it doesn't mean i have
to like everything or to you but if you
see a good episode you like a good
episode you and i disagreed on the
agents of shield episode recently i i
don't like agents of shield but i liked
the sif episode i really enjoyed that
dennis didn't enjoy it as much but it's
just it's just the way it goes um like i
said i want to stress again that the
performances were great uh tyreese that
moment with uh carol and tyree sitting
in the dark there where he had the gun
like you said you know right there and
he was thinking about and he said like i
forgive you that was a great that's a
well-acted scene by very good actors i
respect that it's just
this ah see i can't
without spoiling anything this arc in
the comic books has a lot to do with
carl and his maturity with everything
flipped around i have a carl's character
carl sucks in the show
but in the book i just prefer his story
in there i won't say any more than that
but it's just i just so why do it with
his character though i think that's a
good move if people don't like his
character they don't like in the show
yeah so like you know i think this one
having these two new characters
have this happen to them makes i think a
bigger impact because i i think i would
have been more like you yeah you know
how you're like oh who cares this girl's
annoying i think i would have been like
that if it had been carl i've been like
yeah
okay that's interesting that's a good
point yeah cause lizzie just knew he's
just kind of irritating him oh she is
because she's messed up in the head
she's messed up she does have a mission
she is irritated but she has issues i
think the actress
you know uh for such a young age did a
really good job she didn't portray it
portraying someone that just
just couldn't get it i think she handled
it better than even carl did when he was
uh freaking out you know the episode
where rick's like you know yeah
you know all that so i mean
again it's well acted as well done i
mean scott gimple i believe he wrote
this episode yes he did the show runner
show runner and i loved um clear
last season uh was one of my favorite
episodes
um i would argue maybe my favorite since
season two
uh he's a good writer like this show was
well made this episode was well made i
respect it it's just i just could i
didn't emotionally get into it but i
respect the episode i think it was well
made uh and the director uh he doesn't
recognize this he's actually the
cinematographer on the show oh this is
the first episode he's directed oh it
was yeah i liked the way they did a
really good job yeah like i like the all
the um there's a lot of shots throughout
the window yeah like i love this how it
opens with the window and her kind of
playing with the zombie and then it ends
you know i mean i liked it i loved the
flow of the episode i just it opens with
a fallout three song by the ink spots oh
is that okay yeah all right i i really i
recognize that right from the beginning
i was like oh that's from fallout 3.
right uh also you know another uh thing
about it i like the ending with it was
kind of a mice and men moment with carol
and lizzy yeah look at the flowers just
like george and lenny i don't know if
you guys have read of mice and men you
probably should have because you i read
it when i was in school yeah i think i
read in college yeah i read it yeah i
think in high school so i i think most
of you should have read it by now read
the cliff notes we'll go ahead and just
go go to wikipedia right now so they
they had their georgia and uh uh lenny
moment in there oh yeah i really liked
it because it put carol into a situation
where
it was something that
she obviously did not want to do she
hated doing but she felt that she had to
because
with lizzie what are they going to do
with her
no they can't leave her alone with a
with judith the baby they can't take her
anywhere if they separate they take her
around eventually she's going to do
something that's either going to get
herself turned into a zombie or
uh get someone else killed or turned
into a zombie
it's just
there's the no win situation yeah
even if you leave her behind
someone else let's say finds her
they don't know that about her no yeah
and then something bad's gonna happen
there so it's almost like
she couldn't let that you know be she's
like when those little scary girls from
uh like the ring or something you know i
was like a little horror i mean she's
she was
i mean yeah like i said i like
everything about the episode just i just
couldn't get emotionally involved and i
wish i could i i wish i could talk more
about maybe after after this season's
over with maybe i can talk more about
the comics i don't want to spoil
anything but um it's just it changed
characters and i think the story really
needed to be i liked it when it revolved
around carl even though carl was not
great in the show
it was about his maturity and his
growing up and his becoming different
than he was as a little kid and kind of
becoming a little man and
carol seeing carol do that even though
mcbride did an awesome job acting she
didn't tore that scene up she did a
great job all around i just i just
didn't buy into it i couldn't i think
this episode was meant to pull you in
either pull you into the show or push
you away so i can't wait to see the
comments below whether you guys were on
the fence about it uh did it pull you in
or did it kind of push you away from the
episode whether you've read the comics
or not like what did you think about you
know
well i have to say this though because
i'm going to have a different reaction
because most people that you know maybe
they they're a fan of the show and they
really like this episode i really like
that episode i've been very critical of
of season yeah season four
you know i you know i call it how i see
it right i really like this episode
however i don't think i have the same
reaction as is maybe some other people
in terms of like going okay well that's
it walking dead's back right i i don't
think i have that i i'm still skeptical
yeah like i'm still not sure
if these next two
episodes are going to be
awesome you know like maybe they will be
but this is this is what i mean i i'm
keeping an open mind i kept my mind open
for this episode and i really liked it
so it's not a question of of me hating
the show it's it's
if i think the show's episode is good
then i'll say it's good so i thought
this one was good that doesn't
necessarily mean the next two are they
could be though yeah i mean and that's
like even when i don't like this episode
i do try to respect things that i see i
like i think like i said the
performances cinematography the director
he said the cinematographer beautifully
shot well-acted i i'm not criticizing
the way the show was made it just didn't
connect with me that's just a sign not
every show is meant for everybody this
show started slowly fading away from me
but i do want to finish out the season i
do want to see what happens i am curious
um to see how they wrap this up again
this is the third week in a row uh no
rick no carl no michonne that's
interesting like what i wonder what
they've been up to i wonder if next
episode's going to be like
a step back like it's going to like
flash back to see what they've been up
to it's just going to show them is
everybody going to be in the town all
right next time
i hope not everyone's in the town at the
same time right like hey we all made it
together we're all here hey
that'd be just kind of silly well yeah i
think there is definitely going to be i
saw some preview footage of daryl and is
that new group that he's hanging out
with right right we don't know what
happened to beth
yeah
you know glenn and maggie are still
trying to find each other
so a lot of stuff to wrap up i'm sure
there'll be a cliffhanger what did you
think of
because i really like this moment maybe
you didn't but i liked at the at the
very end because i was talking about
before the tyrese and carroll thing i
was actually talking about before right
no not not in the house not in the house
yeah right but at the end at the house i
felt like i liked that moment that carol
that was the time she decided to confess
because i think she had so much pain
inside and she
almost kind of was like i'm i'm ready to
die like
i'm ready to die like i'm going to
confess to you if you want to kill me go
ahead because here's your opportunity
right this is probably the moment where
she's like
okay
i'm ready for it i think
i like that because i think we we got
more of carroll than we've gotten in a
long time carol i always i didn't mind
her but she's always just kind of been
there but this last you know ever since
rick sent her away
and she's come back i think we've seen a
lot more of her so yeah i think that uh
with carol and it was a very important
scene i think uh
it gave her more depth you know and i
think that she's needed that because i
don't think she felt like that much of
an important character essentially the
group but now she is i mean i can't wait
to see if you know when she's reunited
with daryl what that's going to look
like or maybe her entire eso form of
bomb who knows i mean there's always
yeah they kind of have formed that bond
but now
it's a little broken
even though tyrese forgived her right
forgave her like a little much for him
to yeah i think like the bond that they
kind of had in this episode like they
were gonna
build a home there that i think that's
what that's what brought me in versus
like
you know with mika and lizzie you know i
you know obviously they're not
characters that have been around the
whole series that much i think
what brought me in was the fact that
here they are this kind of weird family
union unit with the baby too they had
the two kids
the mom and the dad and they found this
place and like they were like you know
let's settle down here you know it's
nice that we got this we got the stove
and water yeah we can make this work
make this work and i think that also
contributed to me for me like the
feelings of they lost all that right
yeah and that's why they couldn't stay
because technically not technically but
like realistically they could have
stayed yeah they could have tried to
make it they didn't but meant like
mentally they didn't want to uh
psychologically they didn't want to deal
with what happened there yeah so
that's why they left yeah i mean you
know this is this is a big episode
there's gonna be a lot of curious to see
what the conversation's gonna be like
below i mean this is gonna be uh
this is a intense episode a lot a lot of
this is blowing up on you know twitter
and everywhere everybody's talking about
it yeah people were comparing to i don't
wanna spoil it but people were comparing
to the game of thrones red wedding
episode
i don't think it's quite there
even though i really like this episode
and i think it's one of the best in a
while yeah i don't think it's on that
level and see that's the difference
right there let me say something real
quick before we go
the red wedding i've read all the game
of thrones books and game of thrones the
tv show sticks fairly close uh a game
with the walking dead show kind of uh
goes off on different it sticks more
closely to the books than walking dead
does and i knew the red wedding was
coming but the red wedding i was still
tense during that scene like i was i was
like this even though i knew i knew who
was gonna die i knew what was gonna
happen i was still tense during that
scene but again this episode just it
didn't pull me in so that's that's my
you know it was it was tense for me this
episode i just
just not on that i mean for me the red
one is one of the
best episodes right the television i've
seen so
not the best but one of the best right
and so yeah this but this was really
good especially you know for the walking
dead all right guys so that's what we
thought of this episode you can post
your comments below on the website
thinkhero.com or on our youtube channel
think hero pro make sure you subscribe
to that and tell us
you know what do you think of this uh
did you love it did you hate it i saw
some people said they thought it was
only okay
are you back on the train are you off
the train or you're like me that even
though i really liked it i'm still
skeptical i'm still neat i need more
consistency i need a walking dead to be
you know
five six
really good episodes and then i'll be
back on the back on the train and then
you're also going to find us on twitter
you want to come chat with dennis myself
who who's going with me
who's coming with me
i'm sure there's some people who's
leaving after season four who's out
who's done uh no uh you come chat with
us on twitter
at think hero i'm at griffinde and we
also have a facebook page that's
facebook.com think hero fans and make
sure to like that page and share our
video our walking dead reviews our game
of thrones reviews coming up soon yeah
share those on twitter and facebook and
everywhere else that'll help us out